-So happy you're on the show.
-Me too. Thank you so much.
And what a special night.
My God.
Thank you for
having me here tonight.
-Yeah, please.
-Thank you all for your service.
Thank you.
-That's pretty cool, right?
-Yeah, amazing.
-You know,
we were talking backstage,
and I didn't realize
our paths crossed before,
as we were struggling.
-Yes, before we were, well,
where we are right now, yeah.
It was probably
in the late '90s,
and I saw you at The Improv,
because one of my best friends
was a stand-up --
Elizabeth Beckwith.
-Really?
-Yeah, we went to
The Improv, and you --
I remember you were playing
guitar to a Troll Doll.
-Yes.
-Everyone starts --
-And I was like,
"That guy is going somewhere."
-"He's onto something."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-"I hope he gets out of here,
that poor kid."
Yeah, oh, my God.
-No, you were great.
-Oh, please.
You were born and raised
in California.
-Yeah.
-Do you like coming to New York?
-I love it. I really do.
I love it.
-It's good energy here, right?
-It's so exciting.
It really is, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do you get to come often?
-You know,
the last time I was here
was for my birthday in 2019,
and I got to do --
This may be my
favorite memory of all time.
But I got to --
My good friend Regina Spektor
was doing a residency
on Broadway,
and she invited me to come up
and sing with her
on my birthday.
So I got to be on Broadway,
which was, like,
one of my all-time dreams,
and we got to sing to--
-Did you get nervous?
-Oh, I was terrified. Of course.
I mean,
I always get a little nervous.
Like, I'm a little nervous now.
-Yeah, but you had to get
onstage and --
-Yes. It was amazing, though.
I mean, and everybody sang
"happy birthday" to me.
The whole audience sang
My parents were in the audience.
You know,
my daughter, her father,
his parents, Regina's parents.
-Oh, so it was a family affair.
-Everybody's parents were there.
You know, it was just, like,
the most incredible
birthday gift ever.
-I actually got a picture of
your first visit to
New York City.
Is that possible?
-Oh, yes, that is.
That -- Yes, that is it.
-This is -- How cool is this
for your first visit
ever going to New York?
-I know exactly where this is.
This is the hallway at
"Saturday Night Live,"
and you're with Molly Shannon
and Will Ferrell.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-There's Will and Molly.
-The best. Like, how lucky?
-How did you end up here?
-Okay, so, I had never been
to New York before,
and I was a theater student,
and I was going, you know,
in the --
you know, in Los Angeles.
And one of our teachers --
You know,
I was coming with one of my
friends, Jason, in the picture.
And my teacher knew somebody
who worked backstage
in the wardrobe department.
And she was kind enough to say,
"I'll give you a tour,
and you guys can stay
for rehearsal."
And we were so excited.
But when we got there,
we also had tickets
to our first Broadway show,
and we had spent
all of our, you know, like,
hard-earned
college money on these tickets.
So we couldn't stay for
the actual rehearsal,
but we got to, you know,
be there and meet everybody.
-You left "Saturday Night Live"
to go see --
-Yeah, I left
"Saturday Night --"
Okay, wait a second.
I left "Saturday Night Live"
to go see "Cats."
-"Cats."
-Yeah.
-"Cats." Wow!
-I mean, we had fun.
-No, you've got to go.
Yeah, everyone's gotta see
"Cats," as well.
-But, yeah, no, probably one of
the dumbest things I've done.
-And Molly and Will just --
-They were just crossing.
Like, they were, you know,
going to -- We were all eating.
I got to eat with everybody,
like, at the --
I don't know if it was just,
like, tins with spoons and --
-No. That's the Army.
-Yeah. Well...
-"Saturday Night Live," we have
catering and I don't know.
-Yeah, so, I got to eat catering
with everybody.
And it was like --
John Goodman was there.
But the only people
who really stopped
and took a picture with us
was Will and Molly.
I mean, they made a point of it.
It was so nice of them.
And then, who would guess,
years later,
I would play his wife --
twice in, you know, two movies.
And then he produces our show.
He produces "Dead to Me."
-Oh, no -- And Christina --
-Christina's also his wife.
Yeah, his two wives.
-That's hilarious.
-Yeah.
-How's Christina?
How's she doing?
-She's good.
She says, "Hello."
-Give her my best.
-She said to send her love.
-I love her. Yeah.
"Dead to Me --"
-She's watching.
Hi, Christina. We love you.
-Hi, Christina. We do love you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She is so funny.
-She's the best. She's so good.
-Have you worked with
each other before?
-No. We didn't know
each other at all.
And, you know,
everyone was like,
"Oh, you guys
are going to love each other."
And, you know, you never know
when you meet somebody.
But we just
loved each other instantly
and we were great friends.
-You can tell you have
great chemistry on the show.
How do we set up the show
without giving away too much?
-Well, it's nearly impossible.
But, you know, it's the
last season, so Jen and Judy --
If you know the show at all,
we are always kind of
in trouble and doing something
we shouldn't be doing.
And the FBI
is following us a bit.
And so we're on this wild ride
this season,
sort of finishing up the series.
-Yeah,
and there's a lot of twists.
-There's lots of
turns and twists.
-Yeah. Get ready for -- Yeah,
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Linda Cardellini in
"Dead to Me."
Take a look at this.
-I know.
We have to talk about it.
-Which part?
-That Steve's been found.
-Oh.
Yeah, right.
-I mean, is it terrifying?
Yeah. Have I been having
low-grade diarrhea about it?
Sure, I have.
-You have?
-Yeah.
It's nervous poops.
But I have to tell you,
I've been thinking about it,
and it might not be the
worst thing that could happen.
-No. That's true.
-Okay, when we were
at the hospital,
I kept having this feeling like
another shoe was going to drop.
Although, I never understood
why it's a shoe
or why it's dropping.
I mean,
maybe that's a regional thing.
Anyway, I was afraid
you were the shoe.
-Wait. Me?
How -- how am I the shoe?
-Well, because of
your injuries and stuff,
and you were the only other shoe
that I had at the time.
-Okay.
-But then, when Ben told me
about Steve, I was like,
"Oh, there it is."
-So Steve's the shoe.
-Right.
-Linda Cardellini, everybody!
Season 3 of "Dead to Me"
premieres November 17th
on Netflix.